how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
everything relating to the marvelous
cinematic universe and today we have
some spider-man 3 news
recently tom holland has been doing a
lot of interviews for his upcoming movie
cherry
but of course as he's being interviewed
everybody has to ask him
what's going on with spider-man 3
because there are so many reports and
rumors attached to it it's going to be
an
absolutely insanely big movie even tom
holland himself said that spider-man 3
is going
to be doing something that no other
superhero movie has ever done before
and of course we're all thinking
multiverse with toby mcguire and andrew
garfield which we do have more news
about today
a report of what is happening with toby
maguire
and spider-man 3. tom holland has also
said a few comments
in his esquire interview about
spider-man 3 as well and we'll be sure
to break that all down if you love
marvel and would like to stay up to date
on everything happening be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest videos
as i mentioned tom holland was recently
interviewed by esquire and he's on the
cover right now
and what's very interesting about this
is he actually says some contradicting
things to what he said in one of his
recent interviews and it's actually kind
of revealing
as the interview starts he goes on to
talk about cherry and some other
projects that he's doing and then he
gets into spider-man 3 of course
and it appears that spider-man 3 is
going to be just packed with action and
he said
this entire week of shooting i haven't
done a single shot
right way up i've been upside down all
week
so right away it looks like it might
have a little bit more web slinging
which is what some fans were kind of
complaining about we didn't get to
really see
much of that in spider-man homecoming or
far from home but more importantly he
goes on to say
i honestly have no idea what this film
is about
and i'm eight weeks into shooting it he
says that he's only slightly kidding
now he says that this is mostly due to
sony and marvel believing that he is
going to spoil what is actually going to
happen
which i wholeheartedly believe however
last week
he also said that it was the most
ambitious standalone superhero film
ever to be made that's a pretty bold
statement to make
if you don't know what the movie is
really about he specifically said
i have no idea what this film is about
so at this point it really does seem
like tom holland and sony and marvel are
really just trying to throw us off
on what the movie could be about if he
didn't know what the movie was about he
clearly couldn't know that it's the most
ambitious
standalone film ever as far as the
superhero world was concerned so for
those of you who were worried that he
said standalone film
i think that's just tom holland trying
to throw people off the multiverse trail
and just him trying to get people hyped
for the movie because the same week he
said that the movie was absolutely
insane but he also said that for
spider-man far from home
tom has been known to spoil a few things
here and there so i'm guessing they
haven't really told him much yet
however they did go on to ask him about
the spider-verse and talked about all of
the rumors and reports about casting
decisions and the other
spider-man from other universes showing
up and even the person doing the
interview seemed to catch on that tom
holland had different answers for
certain things
tom holland went from knowing nothing
about the film
to having an absolute answer about the
spider-verse the interviewer said when i
asked
holland about this possibility referring
to the spider-verse
he is suddenly positive he knows what
he's talking about so again even the
interviewer said
he went from knowing nothing to all of a
sudden he's positive he knows everything
but tom holland did go on to say no no
they will not be appearing in the film
unless they have hidden the most massive
piece of information from me which i
think is too big of a secret for them to
keep from me
but as of yet no it'll be a continuation
of the spider-man movies that we've been
making
now this could actually be true or he
may not know about them yet
however we've had multiple reports from
very very credible media outlets stating
that alfred molina's doc octa is coming
back
and jamie foxx's electro was coming back
which doesn't really make sense unless
the multiverse is involved in some way
shape or form which we know it will be
because kevin feige said one division
leads into spider-man 3 and it looks
like
the multiverse is being torn apart in
one division since the last episode
so although this could be true i think
tom is under specific instructions that
if anybody asks him
anything about spider-man 3 he is to
deny the fact that it is a multiverse
film
now of course everybody could be wrong
and it could indeed just be a regular
spider-man film
but again there have been so many
reports from credible people stating
that it is a spider-verse film i'd be
surprised if it wasn't
in fact even today we have a report from
daniel richmond stating that
although toby maguire was having some
issues with the contract for spider-man
3 before he has now
officially signed up for the film and
he's going to have multiple costumes
according to daniel rbk
again it just seems like there have been
too many reports from very credible
sources to say that the multiverse isn't
going to happen
and besides what is tom holland actually
going to say when asked about this he's
not going to be like oh yeah toby and
andrew are great i can't wait for
everybody to see all three spider-man on
screen together in this huge multiverse
film
there's just no way that can happen he
can't really say anything about it
because sony and marvel want him to keep
his mouth shut so i'm not really buying
this
especially because last week he was
talking about the movie and how great
and huge it's going to be and then this
week he said that he doesn't know
anything about it
it just seems like he's trying to hype
the movie up without giving anything
away about it but let me know what you
think about this do you think that tom
holland is telling the truth and do you
think that if he
isn't and it is a multiverse film he'll
spoil it soon it seems like marvel's
being super strict about this one but
we'll see about that so let me know your
thoughts in the comments down below
don't forget to subscribe so you can
stay up to date on all news relating to
spider-man 3.
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
hmm